for as long as there have been poor and
rich people have devised clever ways to
redistribute wealth whether it be taxes
political manifestos or by more barbaric
means but you may still be left
unsatisfied with the current system
wondering where is your cut you after
all are smarter than the average person
yet stuck with an average bank account
today we're going to change that we're
cutting corners and making money moves
because there is a business plan that
can create massive amounts of wealth for
you with minimal effort though you may
have to leave a few ethics at the door
and talking of course about the pyramid
scheme before we begin you should know
what you're getting yourself into a
pyramid scheme is a business plan where
recruits buy into the scheme by paying
people above them and then can recruit
people below them in profit from what
those new people pay in one of the most
popular variants of the scheme is the
airplane game and it works like this you
buy in for $1,500 under someone else as
a passenger and every time the flight
gets filled everyone gets promoted
passenger to crew crew to copilot and
copilot to pilot until after a few full
flights you become the pilot and once
you have a full flight you finally exit
by getting paid twelve thousand dollars
eight times your original investment it
sounds easy enough but there's a very
serious problem this traditional type of
pyramid scheme involving direct buy-ins
is illegal in most modern countries
because the business plan is built on
the idea of an exponential chain of
people which is unsustainable leaving
the majority of the people at the bottom
having lost money which is a bummer if
you have dreams of Egyptian polygons but
to the less scrupulous among you fear
not for where there's a way to make
money hand over fist there is usually a
legal way to do that and that holds true
for pyramid schemes so here are the six
steps to creating a perfectly legal
pyramid scheme
step 1 find a product don't worry it
doesn't have to be that good of a
product or competitive in the open
market because you're not really going
to be selling this product in the
traditional sense a product to a pyramid
scheme is more like poker chips to a
casino they're the legal way you make
money change hands imagine we take the
structure of a pyramid scheme and
instead of the buy-in being cash you
make it a product this way you can say
you're providing a good or service to
your customers even if your customers
are just the people working for you now
there is one thing to think about when
choosing a product in order to pay every
person along the chain of the pyramid
enough it's important that you have high
profit margins and typical wholesale
margins just aren't going to cut it so
triple the price of your product and
call it premium again don't worry about
demand your employees will be purchasing
your overpriced products hoping to get
rich not to save money step two make a
payout structure you might think this
should be straightforward but whatever
you do do not make this simple or
understandable you should have two goals
in mind when doing this one keep most of
the profits going to the top while
making people feel like the bottom has a
chance of making it because poor people
need hope to and secondly you need a
constant stream of new recruits joining
and buying in so make sure the path to
wealth is paved by constantly recruiting
other people not actually selling the
product besides your best customers are
people who work for you anyways you've
made a good payoff structure when people
feel like making it is always a year or
two away and they felt like that for
five years
that completes the fundamentals you've
got your business plan up and running
and now you need some underlings this is
where we get to marketing selling your
pyramid scheme is all about messaging so
focus on what your recruits want money
and time freedom which brings us to step
sell a financial fantasy here are some
examples of what that might look like if
you could close your eyes and imagine
your dream lifestyle your ideal
combination of work and play choose the
largest industry in the world for the
biggest opportunity a match
being part of a company that has created
life-changing financial freedom for
people just like you home on a golf
course half a million dollars 110
thousand dollars a hundred thousand out
a few thousand minimum of ten that the
freedom of owning an online automated
business that's priceless
and bragging about it on the internet
even more priceless but sometimes this
fantasy can backfire if people don't
fully believe it if that happens this
top recruiter says you can still close
them by pointing out the problems in
their lives and using it against them
one of the biggest things that I teach
is stack up enough problems that they
have in their personal life and when you
compare it to the money I don't say
they're in well if you found out that
right now that relationship is on the
rocks you're like dang dude you know
your relationship right I mean you okay
with that what's gonna happen with the
kids like who's gonna get who have you
thought about that
so like Joe would you're gonna do joint
custody is it gonna be like she's gonna
take half and all of a sudden you're
like holy crap okay yeah I need to fix
this thing now if I said I'm like okay
great here's a solution
all problems can be exploited including
marital struggles and family problems
and all problems can be solved by
joining as a final part of this vision
for the fantasy life tell your recruits
they aren't getting hired they're
starting their own company you should
call them independent business owners
for a couple reasons first it minimizes
your legal liability if they aren't full
employees second if you're going to
build a scam off hope there's no better
source than the American dream of owning
your own business now it's time to start
thinking about audience you don't want
to try to appeal to everyone otherwise
you will appeal to no one so you have to
think about who you want to target with
your message which brings us to step
four the three key groups Group one
family and friends biggie smalls once
said keep your family and business
completely separated but Steve Jobs said
think different so while everyone else
is following common sense advice you
will make a family business and business
family like someone who can't help but
shoehorn in politics to every single
conversation you want to teach your
followers that all conversations can be
turned into sales pitches
group two young people nobody is more
gullible and sure of themselves than an
18 to 22 year old so get them while
they're hot naive and young rule 3
poor people whatever you do don't waste
money targeting big fish rich people
don't join pyramid schemes they start
them so instead you want to think
differently and go for the poorest
people you can find you'd be shocked
what hard-working people can scrape
together if you tell them success is
only a purchase away immigrant families
poor areas of town or going overseas to
find entire populations of poor people
are all great options as this recruiter
will show there really is no such thing
as not having enough money I know it's
your first time and by this point you
may feel a little sick about all this
exploitation and there's no shame in
that
queasiness is just ethics leaving the
body but don't worry after your fifth
time delivering empty promises to the
hopeful eyes of a single mother of two
you really don't feel anything anymore
and so you know many of your business
counterparts have already achieved
success targeting Hispanics so make sure
you're not late to the party though and
don't forget to utilize technology as
you do so with Google Ads you can target
the bottom 50% of society choose your
target demographic lower that ad rate
and away you go so you've got your
fundamentals you've got your marketing
and recruiting done
you've got your Google ads running but
soon your workers may get burnt out and
to extend their mileage it's important
to learn how to manage discontent
workers this is a vital part of any
company but especially one where your
employees are doing all the recruiting
and buying and most of them are making
any money step 5
the training attempt failure event loop
the way to keep your independent
business owners committed isn't to make
them happy but rather keep them thinking
success is right around the corner you
can do this by first emphasizing that
proper training takes time you'll tell
them that learning to be an effective
leader is a process and takes practice
this is followed by an attempt by them
to recruit and sell with minimal results
that don't pay much they will get down
on themselves for their failure
at which point you need to make sure to
step in and throw a massive pump up
event or meeting it's imperative that at
each of these meetings you have a couple
examples of people who have achieved
monetary success with your scheme
because this will signal to everyone
else that they can make it prop up those
winners on stage and let the
survivorship bias do the talking anybody
can do it should be your message in
reality of course studies of over 350 of
your competitors have found that ninety
nine point six percent of recruits lose
money but we don't have to tell them
that just keep focusing on the winning
we're gonna win so much and
unfortunately some people may get tired
of winning and if that happens it's time
to move to step 6
cut off the bad apples legal pyramid
schemes eventually get a bad reputation
because they all resemble one another
and no matter how much you convince
people that you're different you will
get a bad reputation in the world at
large which can in turn discourage your
recruits the way to get around this is
not by denying the bad opinions are out
there instead accept misdirect and
discredit them in the past people once
thought the earth was flat seems pretty
ridiculous right at the time people
didn't know any differently the same can
be said for the direct selling and
multi-level marketing industries
comparing the legitimate direct selling
companies to a pyramid scheme or any
type of scam you've done a good job when
you don't have to look over your workers
shoulders you've taught them to monitor
for hate themselves and they will go out
of their own way to avoid negative
opinions about your company all on their
own once you have these six steps
handled you will at last be a successful
and legal pyramid scheme controlling
millions of workers paying pennies on
the dollar for worthless products you
sell back to your workers at triple the
price workers who while trying to make
their own fortune don't realize they are
building doors off nothing but hope
alone you have designed a wealth
redistribution system of such hubris
that Marx himself ought to be envious
except you're taking from the mediocre
and giving to those who truly deserve it
you you who have sacrificed everything
ethics and all for this dream this dream
of being successful of having it all and
finally you can taste it I've got a few
more things to say at the end of this
video and also a word from our president
but first we have to talk about today's
sponsor Skillshare do you like learning
things I think you do I do too and
Skillshare is a great place to do that
it's got thousands of classes and
tutorials from experts to help you learn
things things like animation things like
editing things like photography but
mostly for me I like the editing part
but pretty much you can find whatever
you want if you can think of it they
probably have it even stuff from people
like kurz Gazette in a nutshell I think
that's how you say his name they did a
great class on breaking down their
animation style it's really cool so go
check them out their annual subscription
is less than ten dollars a month and if
you use promo code coffee break link
below the first 500 people will get two
months free so that's it Skillshare
click the link below first 500 people
two months free okay so back to pyramid
schemes real quick before you go pause
pause I'm at the end of editing this
video you probably can tell from my eyes
but I realized I didn't say explicitly
that this is sarcastic or kind of satire
I know I probably shouldn't have to say
that because it's rather obvious but I
don't know if 2019 will have sarcasm
anymore so yeah
yes it is satire don't do that don't
start a pyramid scheme I just wanted to
be explicit about it so no one could
misunderstand me I want to just point
you towards some amazing resources that
I found really useful while doing
research and creating this video
originally I was going to do it a very
serious look at you know multi-level
marketing that sort of thing and I found
super useful the following three
resources for maybe first the dream
podcast go check it out it's pretty new
incredible deep dive research if you
like kind of getting into the nitty
gritty
that's what those people do also Robert
Fitzpatrick
he's an MLM experts been working on it
more than 15 years he let me interview
him he's been a great resource
throughout this so I thank him Christine
Richards Richard of Ryan research she
also let me kind of talk to her for a
while she's also an expert on Eminem's
so go check out her research and once
she's done as well as she had a great
interview on quote The Raven and then
finally dr. John Taylor he was one of
the main sources that I cited here of
from the FTC government where he tracked
how often people succeed in these type
of life legal pyramid schemes he is an
incredible resource as well and now I
just wanna I just want to leave you with
his little gym that I found from our
president if you're in America ladies
and gentlemen Americans need a new plan
the Trump Network wants to give millions
of people renewed hope let's get out of
this recession right now with
cutting-edge health and wellness
formulas and a system where you can
develop your own financial independence
the Trump Network offers people the
opportunity to achieve their American
Dream I'm still looking for dreams I'm
doing damn well in life but I'm still
looking for the dream